foreign
let's go to Jason in Colorado Springs
what's up brother Jason
well you know just partying over here
yes
it's kind of early to be partying in
Colorado Springs but that's all good so
what's up dude yeah that's all right
well I wanted to get your opinion I'm uh
I'm the dad of two boys one just turned
13. and so this is kind of like a
two-parter um I'm kind of wondering in
today's day and age with the internet
and devices and all the things how do
you appropriately have the sex talk and
cover all of that and kind of tagging on
to that what's an appropriate way to
normalize discussions about
relationships and intimacy
it's a great question man
um
can I can I beat you up but not because
I don't like you but just because it
will send a message to all the other
parents is that cool
yeah absolutely because I'm sure I'm not
the only one thinking these things no I
know I know you're not so I'm really
grateful that you called so I think to
start out number one 13 is way too late
probably by seven or eight years
okay okay
um
I think the days uh well let's just
let's just be honest the sex talk as a
singular event is an utter failure
it doesn't work it never has worked it
didn't work for you and me it didn't
work for anyone we know nobody walked
out of the sex talk and they're like oh
hell yeah now I know how to do this and
my dad's awesome and he'll always be a
safe place to go talk about girls I mean
like that that has never happened in
human history ever
it has just been like wow I will I will
never talk to them about anything ever
again because all of my body hurts after
that call right you know what I'm saying
so and honestly that that's part of my
second part of that question is because
when I got that talk my dad wouldn't
even do it my grandpa had a couple gin
and tonics and asked me if I knew how to
put on a condom
I didn't want to talk about any of that
with anyone ever again that's one of the
best sex talks I've ever heard right
there that's that's yeah right
incredible I mean inside it I'll figure
it out and uh but I just want something
better for these kids you know yeah so I
I I think
ultimately the sex talk that idea comes
from a faulty notion and it's about sex
it's about
um anger and rage it even bleeds over
into the conversation about suicide
if we bring it up
that it's gonna suddenly give our kids
insights into something that they didn't
know exists and that's not true because
their bodies exist
and so what our silence does or what our
when we turn beat red in our face we're
like or we get all nervous or when a kid
asks us something innocent when they're
six or nine or ten or four and our eyes
start darting around the room looking
for our spouse or whatever they absorb
all of that
and so the greatest thing parents can do
is just to Norm sex to Norm bodies
because it should be happening inside
their house right so it's uh it's
what's going to change is the details
and degrees right I am never going to go
into gruesome detail with about me and
my wife like into you know what I mean
that's not appropriate my my son will be
in more therapy than he's already going
to be in but the other day my daughter's
seven and I dude I'm just
let me tell you the rules of my house
number one every conversation is on the
table a hundred percent all the time
there is nothing in our house that we
won't talk about or discuss and so
that's just an ethos right and that can
be about religion that can be about
political topics that can be about
anything
we also don't gossip
so we don't talk crap about other people
so my kids know that it's not a
free-for-all and the rule that my wife
and I have is any question that gets
asked whoever gets asked answers it so
there's not a big there's not a big um
production there's not a big it's like
confetti falling from the sky in the big
talk right
um what it is is like the other day my
I'm literally just I'm doing something
in the kitchen and my daughter is
sitting there at the at the counter
she's seven and she just says Hey Dad I
just don't understand this and I was
like what what do you understand baby
dude it could have been I don't
understand how wolf dragons are create
fire I mean it could have been any
number of things coming out of her mouth
and she said I just don't understand how
your part gets into Mommy to make me and
I just started laughing I was like I
guess we're doing this right now right
and my wife walks by and she has a huge
grin on her face because she knows the
rules She Walks Behind my daughter and
just keeps on walking it's not a weird
thing in our house
and it ended with yes we are naked and
my daughter goes oh
but it wasn't a there was nothing weird
about it you see what I'm saying
last night when I was carrying my
daughter to bed and we were hanging out
in my room I was carrying her to bed and
I said hey when we walk by I want you to
kick mom like we're just being silly and
she goes no and I put her foot by my
wife's shoulder and my wife leaned over
and kissed her on the top of the foot
and I whispered to my daughter
I will never kiss her again and my
daughter starts dying laughing right so
that's just an ethos in our house now we
are silly and goofy not every family's
like that and that's okay but I think
the greatest conversation is asking
questions all like just constantly
asking questions constantly you and your
wife talking about it not in a gruesome
or gross way or uh making light of it
but just the kids are going to absorb
what's okay to talk about and what's not
okay to talk about okay the second thing
is
um my parents your parents they got to
play defense
they got to just try to keep Playboys
out of the house
right they got to keep try to keep like
uh HBO out of the house
those days are long gone they're over
and so I don't allow my kids to have
phones and I know I'm weighing the
minority on that and I'm a hundred
percent confident not even a shadow of a
doubt in my life that the Arc of
um the next 10 to 15 years that I'll be
proven correct on that deal but I just
don't allow it
um and then when your kids get older and
you decide to hand them a phone you have
to know I'm handing them over
to every Playboy ever in the human
history is right on their phone every
pornography app every video ever
recorded is on that phone
and
please don't make videos of your own
please don't ask people for photos of
your own because now you're trafficking
child support so I think you have those
conversations very very directly but
listen those conversations have to be
set up early
right so I have a hard conversation with
my son at 12 because his stupid school
just hands them Chromebooks and I tell
them about hey if you put something in
an email to your friends
it will be there for eternity
and I told him about a joke that I
thought was really funny when I was a
kid and how utterly disgusting and
offensive it is now that I know better
and so I I went first leading with
here's what I've done wrong thank God
it's not in writing
and so I start the conversation there so
that in three or four years
I can tell them hey
somebody's gonna send you a picture
of them without a shirt on
please please delete that immediately
and let me know let your mom know and so
I'm trying to set up that so that when I
say hey we need to have a talk it's not
he doesn't his body isn't going to fight
or flight he just knows dad has these
kind of talks with me because he we're
open in the house does that make sense
it does and I I will say if those are
the kind of talks we have had because we
did give him a device and you know we
laid those out pretty pretty frankly
okay if you've got a 13 year old advice
you better have 100 Access to every
every
every keystroke on that thing
absolutely and know that they can get
around it because they're smart right
and the same way you and I got around
all our parents rules but me yeah
um I mean like there's some apps out
there that every text he gets you get
every website he goes to you go I would
have every nook and cranny that thing
covered and again it's it's because
we're handing
I mean we're handing a device to a child
that can ruin their professional life
that's such an extraordinary
responsibility that we're putting in
their hands they can send the wrong text
they can ask I mean and they're 15. of
course they're going to ask somebody to
send a picture I mean they're 15.
I'm not gonna blame a kid for wanting to
see
um somebody the opposite sex naked
they're they're 16 they're 19. oh I
would never like
that's not on them that's on us we're
adults right and so I mean I would have
those conversations regularly
um and and I yeah I'm just making a part
of life and conversation
yeah
um what in your house in your house
where does it get awkward
it's awkward in
uh him getting to getting him engaged in
any of those conversations and I I
understand it because this kid is a
carbon copy of me I mean
I I yeah I know what's going through his
brain right because he's just me just
younger and he's gone from the last
couple years you know from like a pudgy
short kid to also just exploded into you
know
a full a full teenager in a man-sized
body you know I know what's going
through his brain and he doesn't want to
talk about any of it he doesn't want to
he won't even I mean we can go to a
school function he gets plenty of smiles
from the girls and stuff and if we try
to even talk about that he just does not
want to talk about it one bit right so I
think a going first
and hearing you talk about it
so maybe the next time your wife walks
through quietly whisper to him
my God she's beautiful
um and it could never be gratuitous and
never be gross and never be like oh man
I can't wait till no that's
inappropriate for parents and kids
but letting him hear you honor how
beautiful your life is
yeah
asking him hey I'm gonna do something
really nice for her like what do you
think she'd be into
and what you're doing is you're teaching
him to keep his eyes open
right so it's a it's a broader
conversation than just doing it
it's a broader conversation than just
like bras and under I mean the whole
thing is a broader conversation and
keeping your eyes open and what is
dignity what does respect look like all
those things
most of the time
the awkwardness that kids absorb and
experience is reflected somehow in their
parents
yeah and I can't tell you I cannot
describe to you
the millions and millions and millions
of moms and dads who
see each other naked
and have sex
and have babies
and cannot talk about sex amongst
between the two of them
I can't talk about what they're into
what they want to try what they are
awkward about like and it just permeates
the house you know what I mean
and so there's something to be said for
couples if you're gonna raise kids
you'll have to be able to talk about sex
because if you all can't talk about it
God help your poor kids
right and they just grow it's kind of
like if you have one um in-law who's a
little bit out to lunch right and
if you bring it up like one of y'all
gets really touchy about it and just the
kids just learn don't talk about
Granddad because whoa mom gets fired up
yeah it's very similar with sex
if you can't talk about it behind closed
doors your kids are not they're gonna
know it's not okay
okay
are there things that you and your wife
can't talk about or that are weird or
awkward or make you blush
um I not really but also not
there are we talk about pretty much
anything but behind closed doors right
like we're not we're not talking about
there's a lot of things that her and I
just talk about together privately okay
not and it should be in any way it
should be that way you shouldn't be like
hey honey you want to try this like at
the at the dinner table that would no
don't do that right right but I mean
probably the whole you know the full
extent of any of those conversations
happens is between the two of us and
never never in front of the kids there
you go so I think there's something
about
um being intentional about holding your
wife's hand
being tensional about hugging every
morning being intentional about kissing
your wife in front of your kids
yeah um letting your kids see that
you're a sexual being
without being pervy McGee
yeah right and
um I I'm I
I know my kids my son's old enough now
that his kids his friends listen to this
show sometimes and give him crap about
it so I don't embarrass him but I I
I don't really give him an option like
I'll tell him hey we're gonna talk about
this
all right I need the update man he's
like dude nope I need the update man and
so we're pretty open about it pretty
open about it and um I also want him to
have other men in his life that I dude
I'm his dad I know it's always going to
be weird
um but I want him to have men in his
life that he can talk to also
um so whether that's a coach
um whether that's one of his buddies
dads
um
whether that's a minister or somebody
that he trusts from a local church
whatever that is
um that he's got people in his life that
he can talk to and I'm not for several
of my buddies um kids they can call
Uncle John and ask him all kind of weird
stuff and they know I'm gonna tell I'll
be able to answer them and I'm not gonna
turn all beat red
um and I'll ask them you know for help
with Finance or help with you know if my
kid wants to go to trade school or
something I'll call you know junking so
anyway all that to say is this don't
make it this singular event
um and by the way I do believe in events
for 13 year olds I think that's an
important thing but it's a total event
like you're becoming a man now you're
becoming a woman now like you are
transitioning I think that whole thing
is incredible
but that can't be the sex talk with a
period at the end of it talking about
sex talking about body parts talking
about you're nothing is wrong with your
body anything is not one thing is gross
about your body not one thing you should
be ashamed of about your body
um some things are private some things
are not for the world and there's some
great books about that some great
children's books to talk about private
parts and like behind bathing suit Parts
things like that it's great man but
those need to be constant conversations
that start really really young and just
are integrated into the household so
that kids never feel ashamed of
themselves and they never think that sex
is some
great that's just not some mysterious
crazy thing it's just this amazing rad
awesome thing especially inside of a
context and um it's awesome so good for
you for being a great dad man keep
loving your kid and just start the
regular conversation and when he doesn't
want to be a part of it he's he's 13 of
course he doesn't want to be a part of
it
it's your job to bridge that Gap
um and to let him know that it's it's
he's safe and it's comfortable and it's
all good and um
that you think his mom is beautiful too